fluency is one of the most controversial
words in the language learning sphere
one of the most common questions i get
is about how long it took me to be
fluent in
english or french or russian and all of
the other languages i speak
hi my name is luca from lucalampero.com
and today i'm going to talk about
how long it takes to become fluent in a
foreign language
first thing first let me clarify what
fluency actually means
to me fluency is the linguistic ability
combined with cultural awareness to
smoothly
and confidently interact with native
speakers in a meaningful way i talk more
in depth about fluency in another video
so if you haven't watched it definitely
check it out the link is in the
description box below
now when we talk about fluency we should
clarify if we're talking about
just speaking or other skills too if
fluency generally denotes the ability to
do something smoothly
then we should also take into account
the other skill areas of learning a
language
and ask ourselves how long does it take
to become a fluent listener or reader
and
writer too so with that in mind let's
get started the very first factor to
take into account is the distance
between your native and target languages
have you ever said or heard people say
hey language x is too difficult
it will take me forever to learn it
first of all i
dislike the words difficult or hard
because they're often
used to discourage people from taking a
course of action the truth is
the words we use shape define and direct
our thoughts so we need to choose them
carefully
i very much prefer using the word
complex instead of hard
for example you see a complex system is
an entity that is made up of smaller and
simpler parts a human being is a complex
organism
an airplane is a complex object and
language is a complex
linguistic entity and if you see two
languages as two distinct systems
the overall distance between the two
languages can be defined as the sum
of the distances between the individual
parts of those two systems
for the sake of clarity and simplicity
let's suppose that one can define a
language system
according to three main components
vocabulary
phonetics and syntax vocabulary
is the collection of words that make up
a language
phonetics has to do with its fabric of
sounds and syntax
is how single words are assembled to
form sentences each part has specific
features that are unique to each
language
and features that might not exist in
other languages
this in general adds and contributes to
the amount of time
and effort it takes to learn a language
and that is to the overall distance you
need to cover
to reach fluency to me the more distant
the language is from my native one
the more time and effort it takes to
reach fluency in it
to give you a very concrete example
spanish is an extremely close language
to italian my own native language
the vocabulary and syntax are very
similar the overall sound structures are
too
with some differences in intonation on
the other side of the spectrum
korean is as distant as it can get from
italian
completely different vocabulary a
completely different way of forming
sentences
not to mention pronouncing words
japanese is also very distant from
italian but slightly less so since it
shares quite a lot of similar features
in terms of pronunciation but you get
the idea
if the distance between your native
language and your target language
is an objective indicator of how much
time it might take you to learn your
target language
there is a group of other factors that
can make this amount of time
much shorter or much longer i'll call
this group of actors
your personal background and by personal
background i mean
your life experience coupled with your
language learning experience
for instance if you're american and you
have learned french and spanish
learning italian will come much easier
to you than another american
with no experience in second language
acquisition
and having a more solid or less solid
language background can have a major
impact on another additional factor your
mindset
if you have already learned the language
to fluency then you know for certain
that learning a language is something
you can do which is a very
very big deal and you've probably
already developed a learning method that
suits you well
on top of that you might not have the
fearful attitude towards speaking that
many first-time learners have
all of these factors make a huge
difference in the overall amount of time
and effort you're going to put in your
target language and there is one more
thing i wanted to talk to you about
your life circumstances or simply put
how you live and mind you i did not say
where
you live but how to give an example i
myself am italian i live in italy
but i don't speak italian that often
given that i live
and interact mostly with foreigners when
you see a person speaking a language
fluently you should not
ask him if he ever lived abroad or which
books he used to learn
instead ask the following did you spend
a lot of time with native speakers
did you live with them did you go out
and share experiences with them
have you traveled to the country or
countries where the language is spoken
do you possibly use the language at work
his language decisions
ultimately shaped his destiny just as
your language decisions
will shape yours each person is unique
and the amount of different scenarios is
limitless but let me illustrate this
with a simple example
for simplicity's sake let's take two
extreme examples within the language
acquisition world
meet juan a mid-30s spanish guy from
madrid
juan already speaks several romance
languages fluently however he has never
learned catalan
one day he meets a girl from girona a
town not far from barcelona
they begin dating and eventually decide
to move there
juan works online so he's got a lot of
spare time to dedicate to catalan
he hits the books for four hours every
single day
he knows how to learn and on top of that
given his background with romance
languages and his confidence as an
experienced language learner
he starts using language with his
girlfriend with his friends
with her friends and in shops and
whatnot
how long do you think it's going to take
one to learn to be conversational or
even reasonably fluent in catalan
i suspect three months would be more
than enough for juan to get a
very solid grasp of catalan and
start using the language in most
circumstances and now meet john
an american in his 30s who has never
learned a foreign language before
except for a meager attempt at spanish
in college one day
he decides that he wants to learn
russian he essentially has no previous
language background
does not have a clue how to start by
himself
realistically it might take john between
3 and
10 years to learn russian fluently
depending on his future choices
and whether or not he manages to stick
with it
so just to wrap up it's quite
challenging to define a precise
amount of time it takes to become fluent
in a language because
there are a myriad objective and
subjective factors
involved in the process of language
learning i have identified
three main categories of factors the
first one being the objective distance
between your native language
and your target language the closer your
native language
to your target language the less time it
takes to learn and the opposite
is also true second the background of
each learner
contracts or lengthens the distance to
cover
and the more experienced learner the
more likely it is for him to know what
to do
how to do it and the confidence to make
it happen sooner than later
and third the way you live and decide to
live can greatly accelerate your
learning process no matter where you
live you need to find ways to come into
contact with a language
use it and make it part of your life
your efforts will pay off
big time over the long run what do you
guys think do you speak another language
fluently
how long is it taking you to learn one
or more languages to a fluent level
please drop a comment below and don't
forget to check
the links in the description box i've
got a great article waiting for you on
my blog with a lot more
information on this topic as always
thanks for watching
and see you in the next video
[Music]
you